hallo liebe zuschauer und hallo manuel
heute ist sein 13
geburtstag happy birthday to you
alles gute zum geburtstag und das
allerletzte von kari und sein papa du
bist ja heute unterwegs und wir aufrecht
stehen mitten in der bahnunterführung
der flüge ist es ja auch so laut du hast
mir überlegt dass du anderen dreißigsten
geburtstag seine weltreise schaden
willst deswegen feierst du heute nicht
und wir können nicht beides sein aber
wir können die virtuelle grüße schicken
und zwar in diesem video gibt es nur als
erstes werden wir für dich die besten
manuel kommentare ever vor dem meer und
zwar haben wir beide channels durchsucht
jahrelange arbeit werden die besten
kommentare zusammengestellt und visiert
und bleibt dran dann am ende gibt es
noch eine überraschung für mich
[Musik]
manno manuell es was wir in englisch
sagen
eins muss doch herzlich schreibt und
super gemacht meine liebe deinen fans
welche märz
lukas m schreibt haller manuell german
language ja was schreiben wir da eine
weltreise machen wollten
das wünschen wir natürlich auf einen
guten start und wir versprechen jetzt
schon mal irgendwo unterwegs
vw schreibt mehr videos wird manuell mit
naomi anderen schreibt karin barth mit
lästereien greco schreibt ist manuel
beck
2010 hätten die freiheit manuelle
getriebe
[Musik]
alexander stark fragt wollt manuell
hinbringt in dieser schritt das machen
wir alexander aber in zwei jahren will
schreibt manuell ein loch capital
spreads
immerhin 26
anna kasseckert sein
ich hab ja nur so sehr für mich selber
eine frage
zuerst ein manuell china schreibt
sondern auch in der welt
die antwort hat dass mein papa frederico
dann schreib ich finde manuel supernett
intelligenz angenehm gut gebildet und
schumanns er hat eine sehr schöne nagel
und eine wundervolle stimme ich wünsche
ich könnte ihnen persönlich treffen ist
ein sehr großer fan von manuel wie schön
dass er auf diesem video ein t shirt an
hat ja alles gute wenn sich die
permanente kommt mich besuchen in
brasilien
ok halten halte freiburg schreibt die
kommission manuel und tanzen antwortet
dass mehrere raus schreibt manuel ist
weg
also melissa joan manual lieber manuell
ein of your friends and relax von
interviews
ich sah neckar fällt sie weiter ich
glaube gehört zu haben dass pinguine
mehr menschen umbringen als feier hat
nämlich manuel geschrieben sagt in dem
video in einem video und dieser
antwortete hahn er beschreibt manuel
tusch aus dem unglaublichen hinter
konnten das haus noch immer wenn man ein
held ist hintergrund gleich viel schöner
muss aber auch hat schreibt manuel kopp
und abra selber ein monat später hatte
bestimmt viel schreibt paul gesetze oft
perfekte abhängen
nachdem pläne bord aber interviews
[Musik]
gesagt ja lieber mangel das waren die
besten manuel kommentar von unserem
kanal vorgelesen von mechanischen kari
wir hoffen sehr dass es dir gefallen hat
wie du siehst drehen sich sehr viele
kommentare darum wo du gerade bist ob du
weg bist ob du schon wieder da bist
wandel zurück kommst du siehst den
leuten ist es wirklich wichtig dass du
da bist jetzt ist aber erst mal zwei
jahre auf weltreise
wir hoffen aber dass dich diese
kommentare trotzdem motivieren
zwischendurch mal ein video zu machen
und und einzuschicken
denn deutsch lernen kennen wir können
wir überall und wir haben jetzt noch ein
virtuelles geschenk für dich nämlich
einen reisegutschein b bekommst du
später per e-mails und kannst ihnen
virtuell zum beispiel gegen eine
übernachtung eintauschen
und wenn ihr auch etwas schenken möchte
tan manuel dann könnt ihr das tun indem
ihr ihn einladen wie ihr wisst aus
unserem travelling video fahren manuel
und damit für zwei jahre um die welt sie
fangen an in südosteuropa dann der nahe
osten dann nach asien und später nach
amerika und sie freuen sich wahnsinnig
wenn sie euch auf dem weg treffen können
und wenn ihr lust habt sie ja in euer
lieblings kaffee einzuladen oder mit
ihnen eine stadttour zu machen oder
vielleicht habt ihr eine couch zum
übernachten
dann schreibt ihnen doch einfach unter
manuel / service und manuel freut sich
sicherlich sehr darüber und camille von
mir noch mal gute reise sichere reise
erlebt viel lernt viel und teilt mit uns
was sie erlebt hat
herzlichen glückwunsch feiernacht schön
heute und alles gute zu deinem 30
geburtstag ist bei manuell und liebe
grüße aus berlin
manuel und berlin